[Music]
thanks for the opportunity to present
this work here so my name is marm Ros I
work at the University of Ronan the
captin astronomical Institute and today
I want to show uh basically the
solutions we're developing uh to uh to
work with the billion stars and
specifically in the Jupiter notebook so
what you're seeing here are actually a
billion stars
visualized so I'll start with the uh the
motivation like why why did we actually
do all of this uh I'll show you the
solution uh and then I'll give two demos
so I'll start with facts in the notebook
uh and then afterwards I'll um use IPI
widgets and I'll show you IPI volume uh
after that so the motivation actually is
um the Gaia satellite that's uh so it's
in space uh for a few years already and
it's uh constantly scanning the sky and
the goal is to determine really
accurately the uh the positions
velocities and uh like astrophysical
parameters like how much metal for
instance there are in in Stars uh for
more than a billion stars or other
objects in uh in the Milky Way so we
have one data release the first catalog
is out uh it doesn't have all of this so
it has Sky positions and uh magnitudes
so how bright the star is um but it's a
it's a nice catalog to to test this out
so we um we have this data set uh like
more than a billion uh Stars so how do
you work with this you want to like
visualize this you want to see the data
uh for instance one of the things you
want to do is uh quality checks I mean
are there like weird artifacts in the
data are all the reductions done
properly and in the end you want to do
science you want to like plot things see
relationships or clustering and in this
case by visualizing this you're the like
the neural network
looking at the data so let me
demonstrate what the issue is uh so the
traditional way like you do a scatter
plot but uh let me show how it does not
work uh so what I'm going to do is plot
the sky coordinates of uh the uh this uh
data set the Gaia data set um and I
start with a thousand points and I'll go
to a billion points so now we're at so
you see it's a dis we have a million 100
million and basically you see nothing
so instead if we count how many objects
there are in a particular bin and color
it in proportion to how many stars there
in or the log of that then you see much
more detail for instance here you're
seeing the large meulan Cloud one of our
neighboring galaxies and the small
meulen Cloud you see we live in a disy
galaxy with um so some of these features
are like dust features but you also see
that are patterns in it so these are
issues with the data reduction because
uh um the uh the data is just from one
year of getting data so it's nice to
make such an image but can we like zoom
into the LMC like I want to zoom in here
and see what it looks like in detail so
how long does it take to do can we do
this interactively and can we explore
this data set can I like do
selections um so let's first do like a
really simple calculation what what do
we have we have like a billion rows uh
and we have two columns and each value
is like uh eight bytes uh double
Precision floats so you have 15
gigabytes of data and say your memory
bandwidth that you have between memory
and CPU something like uh between 10 and
20 Gigabytes a second so you can
transfer the data from memory to CPU in
in a second so second is resistal and if
you look at the CPU so you take your
desktop with a 3 gahz multicore system
you have something like 12 24 Cycles a
second so you can do a few
multiplications divisions but that's
that's it you can't like draw nice
glyphs or do like complex operations so
you have to keep it simple and yes if
you try it out you can make such an
image in like one second so this is the
fulla data set
again uh few caveats it you need to be
able to fit some of this in memory not
the whole data set but what you're using
otherwise you're down to the uh the
performance of your hard drive and you
need Proper Storage I mean if you going
to store this in comma separated files
it will take you like an hour to just
read in the data um and you need some
simple and fast algorithms for the
binning but that's the simplest uh uh
problem um so how do you store the data
well you want to store it like the CPU
understands it so you don't have to do
any conversion and you want to do it
column based such that if you like read
in a column that it's all sequentially
read right um and we're using hdf5 for
that so let me demonstrate what's
happening if you uh if if you read in
data what are you doing so usually you
allocate a piece of memory here on the
right and then you say to the operating
system well please read some uh data
from file and what the operating system
is doing saying to the hard drive well
put it here in my operating system cache
and then the colonel gets a message or
the CPU and it knows that and then it
copies it to your uh private memory uh
to your
array and uh then your program get a
message like okay it's now you can
continue and what you're doing you're
reading it back again in the CPU and
that's a bit of a waste of like why
would you actually do this can't we like
do this directly access the uh cach of
the memory and that's actually what you
get when you do memory mapping it
doesn't guarantee that that all
operating system uh do this uh it
wouldn't make sense not to do it this
way and you avoid a memory copy and if
you think that's not important I mean
copying 15 gabt of data is already a a
second so that will make it things at
least like two times as
slow so we can create these like uh 2D
density Maps like
histograms so why not go to 1D include
that as well so we can do like 1D
histograms and maybe like 3D histograms
so you can use volume rendering to to
visualize something and to complete it
why not do Zero Dimensional like count
the number of non-missing
values and so now we have like counts
but you can also think of other
statistics so here it's showing the
correlation between two values like here
the velocity two velocity components for
each
pixel and you can do the same in onds or
basically a mean in
bins or Zero Dimensional and in 3D you
can think well I mean you can make a a
calculation in 3D but not visualize it
in 3D but do like
slices and that's what the python
Library effects uh uh does you can think
of it as a um a pandas like library but
then for large data set pretty simple
API just one class to uh to wrap some of
the numpy arrays and the rest are just
like basic data types and uh it focuses
mostly on ND statistics like on regular
um statistics on N dimensional grids
like counts means Max standard
deviations Etc so on a
reasonable desktop computer
um you get about a billion rows a second
so that's 50 times faster than uh Bin
statistics if you're using that and
about two times faster or more than than
data Shader which is try to tackle a
similar similar problem on this laptop
it's it's a bit less than that something
like uh between 0.12 billion rows U per
second uh it's an older MacBook Air and
it's basically CPU bound uh so it
calculates the nend dimensional grids
but you want to visualize this there so
there's some wrappers for mud plot lip
but I'll also show some other ways to
visualize visualize the data so what
kind of data can you use for this
Library well astronomical cataloges like
I showed you the Gaia catalog but there
are more and they more coming like lssd
will be like even larger but also for
ody simulations basically rows and
columns so any tab data and I will show
in the demo I'll use the New York TXI
data set which is a data set uh of
pickup locations and drop off locations
of of taxis um or just like a lot of GPS
GPS coordinates from the uh open street
map uh
website uh but sometimes you want to do
like transformations of your data like I
don't I have a column X and Y but I want
to have the sum of that uh so let's say
these are npy arrays you add them
together and these are like a billion uh
uh values you're wasting 8 GB of RAM so
it's not something you want to uh to do
so what the in what you can do
everything is an expression and not the
8 gabt is uh used but instead it's doing
it in chunks so it's not wasting your
memory and if you use particular
Expressions a lot you can add like a
virtual column like like you would have
in a database and it's calculated on the
Fly just makes it shorter to
use but sometimes you don't use all the
data you want to use like some filtering
so you need subsets but you can't copy
the data I mean the data usually doesn't
even fit in memory so if you make a few
copies that doesn't work so uh you can
do selections and it will keep a Boolean
mask and you can use that to calculate
particular statistics so here I select
everything greater than zero for x and
can give it a name and then you can use
it in the calculation of uh
statistics and for instance uh we'll see
like we have two uh views of the data
and one one thing we want to do we see a
clump here how does it look in the other
panel so let me um uh give you a bit of
a demo to demonstrate uh how you would
use
this so uh some
imports so we import F numpy mod plot
lip I'll make the fonts a bit bigger and
just uh open a data set so you see this
is a a 23 gab data set but there's like
it cost no time to read this in because
it's just using memory mapping it didn't
do anything it just the arrays point to
the data and that's it so in this data
set so this this is the New York Tei
data set for 2015 it contains uh 50
million
rows uh so these are like the columns so
we'll focus on uh the drop off longitude
and
latitude um it's total amount so how
much money they paid and the trip
distance how long the the trip was and
you see some of the data here so let's
start with the Zero Dimensional
statistics well count it's equal to the
number of uh of rows or you can count
like the non-missing values and
sometimes the first time it takes a
little while because it's reading in the
data after that it's uh it's fast you
calculate like a mean and if you want to
calculate uh something like in bins of a
particular value you use like equivalent
to SQL Group by but now it's like
regular bins so bin by and these are the
limits and you get your numi array where
it's the count in these pins you can
plot this this if you want and if you
want to do this in like 2D you instead
you give a list of of columns or
Expressions actually you can give it a
shape for instance this is simply a 2d
array containing uh um the counts in
each SP you can inow that right you can
probably recognize New York but it's you
need to transpose and Etc uh to get the
uh uh the orientation
correct so let me show you how to do so
I'm calculating the limits so I don't
have uh the program doesn't have to do
this all the time so instead there's a
simple plot command so uh to make this
easier for you gives you labels and
color uh color bar so people that know
new York I don't but I know not this is
an airport there are like two airports
they're clearly visible you can see all
the
streets but let's say you're a text
driver where should I pick up people
where where uh where do people pay the
most so you can say what kind of
Statistics to uh uh uh to show so here
the mean of the total
amount so what would be a good place to
uh uh to pick up people
so the um U dark so this is like $50 so
it looks like the airport is a
reasonable place right makes sense but
actually I mean these are probably long
distance strips so uh maybe we should
look at it it like uh per kilometer or
per mile
probably there's a bit of an issue with
the trip distance if you calculate a min
max so you see now it took like 71
milliseconds if I do it again it's much
faster because it's now fully in memory
so there are some outliers there so
let's take a look at the 1D
distribution so I'm considering Now
using select uh everything um outside
this range as
outliers and then what we can do we can
plot like the uh uh how much uh per per
mile people
[Music]
pay and now you see that the airports
may not be the best region actually so
some regions here are much darker than
here so
but
yeah this one
maybe
[Music]
M
okay so the title is uh a billion stars
in The Notebook let me see if the uh no
I need to connect
to should I put it here does
that
yes gives me time to set this
up um so there's uh you can also connect
to uh to another server it's not so
relevant I'm not going to discuss it but
just uh uh so I'm opening now a data set
that's on a a server at our work uh
because I don't need to transfer like
all the data I just need to transfer the
statistics so the the the billion stars
are sitting there on our server and uh
um I I just connect to uh to that it's
over a websocket if you're wondering
what this uh this
means so with uh how long is so it's a
billion billion
rows if this confus you these are python
3.6 six F strings if you're
wondering and now you can plot like a
billion stars it's pretty
fast but okay uh for some applications
this is enough right you want to look at
the data but you want to do this
interactively like zoom in uh select
things so that brings me to uh to the
next demo and for this I need to
introduce you a little bit to IPI
widgets I can't give you like a full
tutorial but but uh uh let me just show
give you a flavor of what it uh can
do don't let stop you there something
weird the
building yeah this is for the recording
so
speak
please yeah so
um yeah
sure this better great so I'm importing
IPI widgets I make a slider and you just
get a slider as you expect you can so
you can like print them out but they're
rich
objects uh text object and I can change
change this to three and it's directly
reflected in the in the notebook so I
can read this out directly or I can set
them actually so they this one and if I
execute this it's directly reflected in
the
go or you can link them together and
actually this updates
itself and if you set them because
they're linked it probably yeah so it's
a rich Library actually I can't cover
all of it but based on this Library you
can build your own
Library um so that's for instance one
library is bigq plot which has a mod
plot lip like uh
interface but instead of being like a
static like image it's
actually something you can like zoom in
ETC so you understand where this is
going
to and you can change things from The
Notebook so if you change it it directly
updates it so
you can do things like
selections and these selections you
again it's synchronized to The Notebook
so you can read out what's selected or
the other way around you just so this is
like
synchronized um so another package
that's like an a leaflet so leaflet is
like a shows you like a map like Google
Maps so IP leflet Bridges this uh so
that you can use it in The
Notebook
so we're somewhere here and you can add
like layers on top of this like
images
so so maybe you see where this is going
to so now I'm so I'm in a separate
notebook this is a separate like kernel
uh and I opened the New York texi data
set again it doesn't cost me any extra
memory because the because of memory
mapping it's actually using the same
memory so you don't need any extra for
that and instead of plot I use plot
widget and I tell tell the uh to use the
IPI leaflet back end so now you can
overlay the whole data set on New York
and you can zoom in and on the fly it
will calculate uh like the density uh
this density
map
um but you can do more and I implemented
some like simple uh uh uh say types of
plots so what I'm doing I'm showing the
drop off locations
but I'm using a third axis which is the
uh drop off hour and I'm making 24
slices for the uh for each
hour and I uh connect like a slider to
this to show me the uh the hour so this
is midnight and let's focus on this
region it's now pretty
dark uh so I don't have a color map yet
for this for the widget so uh this color
scale so um low is um uh like a a dark
color and bright color is
high so if we go to the morning then all
of the sudden so this space
becomes really bright so there are lots
of people being uh dropped off at this
uh place but it I noticed this because
like later in the day nobody wants to go
there for some reason
so so is this like a bad area
like it's close to it
actually but it's a a Convention Center
I mean why would you go there in the
evening so you can see that everybody
most people some early but most people
arrived there at 89 makes
sense um so for the last uh
demonstration I'm switching to a
different data set so this is a
simulation because we don't have the
full data set yet of a of um what we
believe the Halo component of the Milky
Way looks like so that's like the
spherical component so not the flat dis
but more the stars and we believe
they're uh for a large part made out uh
of like smaller galaxies that mixed that
are mixed together and similar in this
simulation so what you're seeing here
are actually 33 like smaller satellites
mixed together and you can't distinguish
them but if you look in other spaces
like um uh energy momentum around the Z
axis which is the Symmetry axis of the
system and the energy then you see
actually that there if you can count
them uh 33 blobs in this space they
still recollect they still have memory
of of uh uh how they started before they
were mixed and now you can like select
this and see hey this is indeed like one
of these uh objects but
uh thank
but our galaxy is 3D right so um um we
want to see what this looks like in uh
in 3D and it will look really different
well quite different in 3D um so we want
to have a a 3D visualization library or
plotting Library uh for the notebook but
uh there wasn't anything at least not
some something I could use so what do
you do you make it yourself um so that
resulted in a python package called IPI
volume it's a 3D plot for the jupyter
notebook so it's based on the IPI
widgets and using webdl for rendering
it's pretty young started around
Christmas and uh what it currently can
do is like glyph rendering plus volume
rendering and um um what's nice uh uh
since IPI widget 6 is
out if you look at the documentation you
can actually like put Snippets of code
in there and you can look at the output
and it's like interactive so this is the
document
oh sorry glyph is like um like in 3D
visualization like like these like these
are spheres can be like
symbols or C quiver plots like
arrows um and because it's uh it's based
on IPI widgets you can
uh uh connect sliders to it for the
size or like a Color Picker and and
that's nice thing because I didn't make
this but because it's uh well I the 3D
part I did but not the sliders but
because it they're all iPod and widget
they all Like Glue together and you can
make like small uh applications with it
there's one thing funny thing that I
needed to do uh to do and that's this
button um because it's in the browser
you can do uh uh you can also do it on
your phone and if you have like a Google
cardboard you can do like for
it's uh it's a bit of a gimmick but uh
it's way cheaper than say an OAS Rift so
if you just want to try something out
it's uh
I I bought like one of
these so so you can try these this this
doesn't work for me for some people it
depends on like uh your eyes but this is
like 15 and you get like a USB
controller I didn't uh have that but you
can also connect that to it but yeah to
me it's convincing but it's a bit of a
gimmick so what does it look like in Co
in code so the most important thing for
me was volume rendering because you have
like 3D cubes and you want to like
visualize that so um this is just a
function that I'm I'm plotting here and
you can change like the transfer
function if that means anything for
you um but I needed also Cliffs um like
Scatter
Plots like here and um instead of like
okay maybe I need to change the color to
Green you can just set it from The
Notebook change the size and and change
that and you'll notice that everything
is uh um like interpolated Everything
Changes slowly that's actually inspired
by BQ plot which was using D3 and I
thought it would it it helps instead of
something like suddenly changing you see
things slowly
changing um and that actually so uh
someone noticed this package and he
needed it for
a um he he basically needed
animations um so that resulted in a pull
request and some some polishing on my uh
my side and some some additions and what
you can put in is like a sequence of
data sets for instance here and because
the everything is interpolated also
prisions and and directions Etc you can
get away with a really coarse time step
and it gets
interpolated so you
can do this and this also runs out of
like in the browser so you can bring
this like to a meeting for instance on
your tablet
[Applause]
uh oh yeah and ear uh uh early Easter
egg you can render
cats they're Point not pointing the
right direction but I'm working on
this but rendering cat was not really
the real purpose of this so the
uh what I wanted to do is to have um a a
3D back end for uh uh for fact so take
3D volumes and uh also grits on on a
corser uh um scale to visualize not only
like the densities but also like the uh
the
velocities so this is the same structure
that you saw above um but there's an
issue so the uh it's also showing like
really low density regions and it's
plotting a like a a vector there and
again you can reexecute this or you just
like you stop completion and find what's
there and there's this attribute and if
you change this you don't visualize the
ones that have like small counts like
50 so you can change this maybe this
should be like 60 or
70 oh I changed the
color let's change this a
bit so now this is so let me go back so
this was the
uh the
2D uh 2D version of this uh what we
would call a stellar
stream and this is the 3D version and
you have a much better idea how this
object look like in in 3D and you can
also see so these are the velocities so
the mean velocity at each uh uh position
how this stream is moving in
space
so say you want to change the color in
red or you don't know and you just like
on the Fly you can attach a Color Picker
to it and change the color of the uh of
the glyphs all thanks to IPI
widgets um or uh if you want to show
this to a colleague or you want to uh
bring this to a meeting on your
tablet you just save it to uh
HTML and you
can maybe do
stereo um
um yeah so uh to finish off with the uh
I mean I was talking about the billion
stars and the Jupiter notebook again I'm
connecting to uh uh to the
server
um and I'm just showing all the data you
can like interactively zoom in and it
takes
about it should take a second maybe
sometimes the first time it takes
longer yeah
and so this is one of the uh the um our
neighboring satellites the large metalen
cloud and even if this is a billion
stars you can just make a selection like
this cluster
here and make maybe like make ond uh ond
histograms so
uh yeah so they're uh well if you if you
know what what these objects are this
probably makes sense to you but just to
demonstrate what you that you can do
selections for a billion
stars so to conclude so uh I showed you
effects which can handle n dimensional
statistics on on regular grid it can do
on a reasonable desktop about a billion
uh rows per second uh can do efficient
transformations of data so you can
calculate the mean of a particular
expression um and these can be used for
visualization like um I showed you m
plot lip but you can build your own I
mean if you have imow that's basically
enough and you can do this interactive
now in the uh in the notebook thanks to
IPI widget BQ plot and IPI leaflet and
also in 3D uh for IPI volume which adds
uh 3D interactivity uh now which can
also be used for facts and uh also works
outside of the uh the notebook in the
browser so you can put it on your tablet
or or give it to uh to colleagues so
that's it thank
you oh